what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the latest crazy
developments in the demon Slayers story
moves on Anton general after all these
chapters are finally face to face and it
seems like this could be the final
battle so definitely stay tuned for that
if you enjoy seeing demon Surtur videos
on this channel make sure to smash that
like fun to let me know I'm more than
happy to keep making these chapter views
as long as you guys want to keep seeing
them if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is especially important hit
that notification bell because if you
don't you won't even know when future
demons their videos come out for more
demon Surtur content and crucial updates
about the new movie and seasons falls on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
lastly there will be spoilers in this
video we are going to be looking at the
latest chapter chapter 181 after all so
you've been warned
now without further ado let's jump into
it so last chapter was insane moves on
was unleashed and as one of the comments
mentioned he looks less like the King of
Pop and more like Iggy Pop now but
musician like appearances aside he
killed more people than we've ever seen
killed in one chapter he just prance
through them and used all those
relatively weak demon Slayers to recover
at this point anyone below a pillar
level of power is just a liability
they'll just help moves on gain power
quicker which is why I don't completely
understand what kiria expected those
demon slayers to do against moves on and
understandably it seems like kiria
is pretty shaken up about what's
happened however we shouldn't be too
hard on him keep in mind kiddie ax is
only like eight years old so the fact
that he's gotten this far is pretty
impressive chapter watching anyone it's
called disaster and you know with a
title like that that things are about to
get real interesting in the beginning of
this chapter we get some much-needed
character development from kiria and his
sisters kiria as mentioned is freaking
out and doubting himself because of
what's happened he blames himself for
everything because he made the wrong
call musong slaughtered many demon
Slayers Kiryas starts to believe that
it's already all over he starts to
believe that he has messed up things
beyond repair
he thinks that everything everyone has
done for centuries to defeat Mouzon will
all amount to nothing and it's all his
fault he is absolutely paralyzed I think
that this was an important scene for us
to get I've been thinking since these
kids were introduced that they're way
too calm cool and collected for kids
especially in all of these high-stakes
situations so this scene shows us that
yeah they have doubts too but they're
doing their best to overcome them most
of the time then the paralyzed kyria
gets a much-needed slap in the face from
his sister in anime sometimes you just
need a good slap or punch in the face to
get it together think calming a punching
Simone in the face and telling him to
grit those teeth in good and logon and
this does the trick for kyria he snaps
out of that frozen fearful state his
sisters tell him to be strong and to
hurry up and give the next order since
the fight isn't over yet that's the
thing you can't give up before it's
completely over while they have a
fighting chance no matter how small
gideon needs to keep himself together
after all they have so many powerful
pillars left and the three demon slaying
musketeers including kanjou decided to
annie noski kiria realized that he's the
master now and part of being the master
of the demon slayer core is this
pressure he realizes that his father
grandfather and all the others had to
deal with the same pressure and hardship
if they managed to do it then he can too
besides he has no choice everyone is
relying on him and as we know from anime
having people to protect always makes
you stronger and able to cope with
bigger challenges when this all finally
sinks in he's back to normal yeah a
bunch of people are dead but he still
has to help out those who remain as best
as he can he starts giving orders for
the pillars and other members to gather
in one place he wants him to close in on
moves on so pretty much one giant tag
team effort he then thinks his sisters
for helping him to snap out of his
paralysis they're crying showing how
hard it is for them to after all they're
even younger than Korea we then jumped
to meet suti the love pillar and a guru
the snake pillar who are still fighting
upper moon for na ki may the Biwa demon
a crow tells them
about Mouzon and that the pillars have
to gather it's extremely impressive that
upper moon for while doing everything
else was able to stall two pillars while
not taking any damage herself as the
snake pillar points out
he's just been wasting time and energy
while the others have actually been
defeating demons I really wanted to see
this guy go all out but he doesn't seem
too strong at this point
egor decides that he needs to somehow
get away from upper moon for while meet
suti is surprised by the order that they
want her to ditch that be one player
then someone grabs her but the question
is who let me know your thoughts on who
it is in the comment I don't know if
they'll be able to escape without
defeating upper moon for but it would
definitely be better if they did manage
to defeat her if they don't she'll
definitely be able to pose many problems
for them later plus it would really mean
that they accomplished nothing while the
other pillars were fighting and dying in
order to defeat the other upper moons
the only question is what would happen
to this dimension if they were to do
that then we jump to moves on himself we
were told to chapter before that he
wasn't close to Gil but chances are the
be-what player transferred him over to
their location so we get the
long-awaited face-to-face reunion
between Tanja and Mulan sooner than I
thought we would tundra is clearly very
much affected when he sees moves on his
breathing goes out of control as he
remembers how his family including
netskope suffered because of him he also
thinks of the demon Slayers he knew who
died while trying to stop moves on in
his upper moons the list includes ganya
mu Ichiro Shinobu and of course the
legendary a tengoku by the way the how
strong is an goku video is ready for
publishing
it'll be out soon if it isn't already so
make sure to check that video out where
I not only look at his strength but also
at his epic and motivational personality
back to the chapter at this point we see
Tanja no grip hard on his sword and we
see the collar of his sword which he of
course got from the dango coup so
symbolically it is very clear that n
goku and the others are still with them
in spirit their sacrifices made it
possible for tantra and the others to
get this close to beating moves on if
they win it will only have been possible
because the
ultimate sacrifices that their fallen
comrades have made Tantra is arguably
more angry than we've ever seen him
which makes sense all the suffering he
and his friends and family have been
through can be blamed on the demon in
front of him he's been waiting for this
moment since the beginning of the series
he even has to tell time zero to calm
himself down
although ghee is also not his usual calm
self then Mouzon gives an interesting
speech it's actually kind of funny how
calm he is compared to how on edge
Tantra and gr moves on comments on how
persistent they are he says in a
matter-of-fact way that he's getting
sick and tired of the demon slayers
and he's losing his patience he says
that demon Slayers are always yapping
about avenging their parents or children
or siblings then he comments isn't it
enough that they're still alive Tantra
and you seem shocked to hear this Mulan
continues talking he says so what if
their loved ones died they should
consider themselves lucky that they
survived and just carry on with their
lives Mouzon wants them to think of him
as a natural disaster he says that the
demon seer should think as if their
family friends etc were simply met with
disaster like rain wind volcanoes and
earthquakes Mouzon points out that no
matter how many people these natural
disasters kill no one seeks revenge
against them the dead won't return to
life after all so he suggests that the
demon slayers give up their grudge and
pursue a quiet life after all that's
what most people do the demon slayers
don't because according to Mouzon their
abnormal coming from the demon God
Father who has teeth all over his body
that's a pretty funny comment he finally
says I started dealing with them and he
just wants it to end in turn ton zero
tells moves on that they cannot allow
him to exist anymore and that brings us
to the end of the chapter the quite
possibly final battle has been set up
nicely our main characters finally
face-to-face with the main antagonist
he's been pursuing since the beginning
and they are both committed to ending
this once and for all
Mouzon speech was interesting but
there's a problem with its logic he
wants them to view him as a natural
disaster but the comparison doesn't
really make sense for a few reasons
for starters moves on his human Ennis
the earthquake isn't there are demons
who managed to stop killing humans and
even the ones that didn't had a good
degree of choice as to how they live
their demon life
similarly moves on like a human is in
control of many of his actions he
actively chose to create upper moons he
chose to kill more humans than he needed
to and he is consistently choosing to
act in a way that we would characterize
as evil then there's the second aspect
of it the demon slayers can in theory
stop Mouzon while they cannot hope to
stop natural disasters like earthquakes
since it is potentially within their
power to stop moves on from killing
other innocent people
it makes sense that they'll do whatever
they can to stop him furthermore it's
not like moves on his Moby Dick moves on
knows exactly what he's doing and he's
not chilling in the sea he's actively
killing humans on land he's coming to
their homes and killing them for these
reasons it is clear that he must be
stopped after all if he wasn't the demon
population would grow as the human
population continued to decline
eventually it would become impossible to
stop the demons and save the humans the
question is could this be the final
battle in demon slayer
in my view it is definitely a
possibility even though I'd love for
this series to go on as long as possible
however if we look at Full Metal
Alchemist the series that has a lot in
common with demon slayer then it seems
possible that it could wrap up soon
Demon Slayer and full metal alchemist
have some interesting similarities aside
from the fact that they were both
written by female mangaka their main
characters appeared to be similar as
well their main cagers not motivated by
trying to become the best they're not
trying to be Hokage Pirate King wizard
king or any other kind of king in both
cases the protagonist is trying to save
his sibling I lost his human body and
ethical similarly lost their human body
when it became a demon body they're both
amazing Shonen manga and I'd say that
Demon Slayer has definitely taken
inspiration from Full Metal Alchemist
Full Metal Alchemist wasn't that long
compared to shown in like one piece in
Naruto it had 64 episodes and demon
Slayers already at 181 chapters the
manga is arguably far enough to already
have more episodes than 64 so it
definitely could be approaching its
conclusion moves on is the main
antagonist after all and this fight has
been
up from the beginning Tantra with your e
cheese earrings is clearly set up to be
his successor and asked his successor he
will most likely finish with you and
ichi started using the dance of the
fire-god aka the breath of the sun'
style on the bright side the fight
itself could definitely last a while
potentially Mouzon could escape without
killing everyone but that would be
unlikely in my opinion if we take this
setup into account but let me know what
you think I would love to hear from you
in the comments and that is it for this
chapter review thanks for getting
intense and it seems like in the next
chapter we might get the fight that
we've been waiting for since chapter one
although we could also take a detour
with the Biwa player versus the love
pillar and the snake pillar too either
way I'm excited to see how the demon
Slayers get out of this one and I'd love
to see mezack will make a reappearance
as well not to mention that into and in
escape it feels like it's been way too
long since we've seen that if you did
enjoy this chapter of you and want to
keep them coming make sure to smash that
like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
very important hit that notification
bell so you actually know when you Demon
Slayer videos come out for more Demon
Slayer content and crucial updates about
the new movie and seasons falls on
Twitter and Instagram and anime uproar
thanks again for everything and until
next time see us space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]